All right, let's do a deep dove into correcting
lies.
This is difficult in our current political
climate.
Donald Trump yesterday absolutely collapsed
like a house of cards under basic questioning
by ABC News David Muir yesterday.
Trump was in Arizona, went to a mask factory,
didn't wear a mask.
Total propaganda visit.
But in the middle of it, Trump was interviewed
by David Muir of ABC.
He didn't really do anything special other
than be a basic journalist asking Trump specific
questions and waiting for an answer.
And Trump's disintegration.
Trump became aerosolized.
Let me put it that way.
That was the degree of disintegration.
It is really something to behold.
I'm going to do something that's a real pain
to do, which is I'm going to fact-check three
minutes of a Trump interview.
And it's so lie riddled that you will notice.
It takes a lot longer than three minutes to
do the fact checking.
And as usual, more people hear the lie.
Very few hear
the correction.
The correction is more work.
This is what we're up against.
But let's do it.
Let's do it together.
OK.
So let's start with David Muir presents Trump
with a quote.
The quote is one you've probably heard before.
Trump said 15 cases are soon going to go to
zero.
Let's dig in.
I'm going to try to fact check set you so
that you can understand how these lies are
spread and perpetuated.
And they become actually like an alternative
truth to Trump is that they repeat.
Let's get into the first question here.
There was one thing you said that perhaps
you could clarify.
You said this this was at the end of February.
A full month had gone by.
You'd stop travel from China.
And you said of the cases here in the U.S.,
when you have 15 people and when the 15 within
a couple of days is going to go down to zero.
That's a pretty good job we've done.
Help me understand that moment.
Did you really think we were going to have
15 cases in the U.S. and a lot limit?
Jeremy, I said even I would say worse than
that.
I said one person one time.
And it's true.
There was a time when we had one person in
this country.
We knew about it.
We worked on it.
We had one person.
It mushroomed to fifteen people.
Mushroom.
Other people were coming in also from Europe.
So already we have to think this through.
The question was when you said we have 15
and they're going to go to zero.
How did you come up with that?
Walk us through how you decided 15 cases were
going to go to zero.
And Trump says, well, it was true.
You know, at one point we did have only 15
cases.
At one point, we did have only one case.
That wasn't the question.
And one tool that's really important to have
when you're trying to pass lies from from
government officials or anybody, is are they
answering the question that was asked, have
they given an answer and Trump has not.
The question was not did we really only have
fifteen cases at one point?
Of course.
Right.
I mean, we now have 1.2 million official cases.
At some point we had zero.
You have to go
through the number 15 to get there.
There's no question about that.
That wasn't the question.
The question was, why did you think fifteen
would go to zero? Trump doesn't answer it.
Let's continue.
Now, Trump pulls out this sad piece of paper
he'd been carrying around all day and it gets
very, very gaslight at this point.
Take a look.
Don't forget that we're at more than a million
doses in January.
OK.
Let's talk about cases.
You know why you're in many cases?
Because we have more testing than anybody
else.
If we test it as much as these countries down
here, OK, who don't do very much testing at
all.
Look at Japan.
Very little testing.
They're at the bottom of the wrong.
Look at South Korea.
Get so much publicity.
President of South Korea's a friend of mine,
President Mauney, called up.
He said, what you're doing with testing is
amazing.
If I tested this number of people instead
of this number of people, I'd have far fewer
if I say this line goes all the way up over
seven million tests.
OK, so the graph that Frump pulls out is a
linear graph of the total number of tests
that were done.
And this is really important to understand
because it's one of the key disinformation
sources right now, Trump brags.
We've tested more than 7 million people.
Now that's true.
But this is a country of 331 million people.
I'm going to sound like a broken record here.
But what matters is per capita, per capita
testing, the U.S. testing seven million is
different than France testing seven million
because France has a much smaller population.
As an example.
So when you look at a sampling of testing
per capita, you would see that, for example,
Iceland, a small country for sure.
Iceland is second in the world in testing
per capita.
They've tested about 150000 people for every
million of population.
Now they don't even have a million people.
Israel is 13th in the world.
They've tested forty nine thousand people
per million.
Portugal is 15.
Spain is 20th.
Norway is 26.
The United States is forty first in testing
per capita.
We've tested about 23000 people for every
million people we have.
We are ahead of the U.K., for example, the
u.k.'s forty fifth.
So this is a lie.
Trump won't stop telling.
We are forty first in testing per capita.
Let's keep going with the area.
If I tested down here at 1 million tests,
I would have a lot fewer cases.
I understand the argument you're making.
Look, look at your question.
But you understand there's a huge disparity
between 50m and more than a million cases.
What was it, an intelligence failure?
Where was the breakdown that we didn't know
the scope of this?
Look, let me let me tell you this.
I closed the border.
If you want to use that term, I banned people
from coming into China.
There were approximately 40000 Americans.
If you were in my position, you would let
them come in.
You could ask Rhonda Sanchez, great governor
of Florida.
Those people went through quarantine, they
went through tests, they went through everything.
But they were American citizens.
I haven't let them come back.
But I came in.
And what I did is I said against many people,
including Anderson, is how she who I like
very much, including Deborah, who are like
very much the doctors and many other people.
Again, Trump says he closed the border to
China.
Now, it's true that went into effect on February
2nd.
But understand, by that point, forty five
countries had already closed travel to China.
OK.
It's also not an answer to the question.
An absolute collapse of a performance by Donald
Trump.
Here's another portion.
Trump has repeat repeatedly used this phrase.
The cupboards were bare when I came in.
And what that means is Barack Obama left me
undersupplied.
And Trump has used the term to talk about
the military.
We've already debunked that.
That's not true.
And Trump has also applied this to PPE for
a pandemic.
Here, David Muir asks him, OK, you know, you've
used this phrase.
The cupboards were bare.
What did you do to restock the cupboards?
And Trump essentially says, well, you know,
I was actually busy with impeachment.
Take a look.
You know, you're three years into your first
term.
You're now applying for the job again.
What did you do when you became president
to restock those covers that you say were
bare?
Well, I'll be honest.
I have a lot of things going on.
We had a lot of people that refused to allow
the country to be successful.
They wasted a lot of time on Russia, Russia,
Russia.
That turned out to be a total hoax.
Then they did Ukraine, Ukraine, and that was
a total hoax.
Then they impeach the president of the United
States for absolutely no reason.
And we even had one hundred and ninety seven
to nothing vote by the Republicans.
Understand, my friends, that one of Donald
Trump's main defenses of how he handled Corona
virus is I was given a bad situation by Barack
Obama and I fixed it.
I filled the cupboards here.
He's given an opportunity to say exactly what
he did.
He could tell us how he filled the cupboards.
And he says, well, you know, I was pretty
busy with impeachment.
I was pretty busy with the Russia probe and
all of that stuff.
David Meher gives him the opportunity to silence
his critics and say exactly what he did to
fill the cupboard and he can't do it.
Now, let me tell you the truth in this.
This this is sort of a bigger picture story.
The truth is that Barack Obama handed Trump
a pandemic response team and Trump disbanded
it and bragged about disbanding it in 2018.
The truth is, Barack Obama
handed Trump a pandemic response playbook,
69 pages and color coded.
We've looked at the document, very good document.
All Trump had to do was follow it.
And Trump didn't follow it.
That's the truth.
And Donald Trump unable to withstand just
basic questioning by ABC News David Muir.
So Trump had to stop press briefings because
they were doing more harm than good, especially
after that bleach injection fiasco.
Now, Trump is doing an actual sit down interview
with someone other than Fox News.
And it goes horribly wrong.
Trump has no choice, seemingly, but to just
do propaganda roundtables with CEOs because
everything else is going horribly wrong